[Applaus]
[Musik]
wenn ich die Schweiz erwähnen Decken
sicher viele von euch automatisch an
Banken Schmuck und Tresore die Mutter
aller Steueroasen das Land in dem das
Geld niemals schläft das Land in dem
Bankkonten viel wichtiger sind als Essen
na liege ich damit falsch wahrscheinlich
nicht doch der Dinge haben sich in
letzter Zeit stark verändert ja genau
die Schweiz ist nicht mehr das was sie
einmal war und Zugang zum gemeinsamen
europäischen Markt zu erhalten musste
die Schweizerische Eidgenossenschaft
viele Zugeständnisse machen zum Beispiel
musste die Gesetzgebung zum
Bankgeheimnis komplett geändert werden
Reformen die natürlich Folgen hatten
[Musik]
tatsächlich ist die Schweiz in vielen
Rankings die den Grad der
wirtschaftlichen Freiheit eines Landes
bestimmen nach und nach immer weiter
abgerutscht okay zugegeben die Schweiz
hat immer noch sehr niedrige Steuersätze
und ist laut der Heritage Foundation
Rangliste nach wie vor das zweitbeste
Land der Welt was die wirtschaftliche
Freiheit angeht aber wenn wir uns den
heutigen regulierungsgrad des Landes
ansehen ist ist nicht mehr das
paradiesische Ziel von eins in der Tat
ist das Alpenland in der isofling
Business Rangliste der Weltbank immer
weiter zurückgefallen heute steht es
auch Platz 36 zum Vergleich 2008 ist
noch auf Platz 19
dennoch wir sollten seinen Niedergang
nicht so vorschnell prognostizieren die
Schweizer haben nach wie vor und bieten
den Rest der Welt eines der besten
gesetzlichen Sicherheitsnetze für
Investitionen erspartnisse oder einfach
für die Aufbewahrung von Vermögen und
ich spreche nicht nur von Geld
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die Schweiz ist ein Skiparadies eine
Industriemacht und ein wichtiges
Technologiezentrum aber vor allem ist
sie ein gigantischer Tresor Geld
Kunstwerke Juwelen praktisch alles was
teuer ist wir haben hier auf
visualpolitik zum Beispiel mal früher
ein eigenes Video über die Schweiz und
die kunstindustrie gedreht und was soll
ich sagen praktisch jeder vertraut dem
Schweizer Franken und wir haben bereits
auf unserem schwesterkanal
visualökonomic erklärt warum aber wie
ich bereits erwähnt habe hat sich in den
letzten Jahren viel verändert nicht nur
weil die Schweiz nicht mehr voll und
ganz ihrem Beruf gerecht wird sondern
auch als zunehmend Konkurrenz
aufgetaucht ist heute gibt es andere
Länder auf der Welt die sich sogar üben
können bei der Lieblingsbeschäftigung
der Schweizer Boden gut zu machen sie
sind der neue Treffpunkt für Millionäre
und Milliardäre aus der ganzen Welt
tatsächlich gibt es ein Land das die
Schweiz nicht nur in vielen
Finanzbereichen bereits sein dank seiner
geographischen Lage auch zum neuen
Zufluchtsort für die großen Vermögen der
Welt werden könnte na habt ihr eine
Ahnung über welches Land wir hier reden
nein es ist nicht Dubai viel besser
Singapur
[Musik]
na hättet ihr das Erraten ohne es aus
der Überschrift bereits zu wissen aber
falls ihr mir nicht glaubt dann schaut
euch doch mal folgendes an der Schweizer
Finanzplatz steht unter wachsendem
globalen Druck laut der Boston
Consulting Group wird Hongkong die
Schweiz wahrscheinlich überholen und
damit die mehr 200 Jahre andauernde
Dominanz der Schweiz im Bereich der
privaten grenzüberschreitenden
Vermögensverwaltung beenden Singapur
wird die Schweiz in den kommenden Jahren
sogar fast vom zweiten Platz verdrängen
ja ich weiße Nachrichten steht Hongkong
im Mittelpunkt aber es gibt einen
kleinen Haken bei dieser ganzen Sache
Hongkong ist zwar ein sehr wichtiger
Finanzplatz aber Hongkong ist vor allem
auf China spezialisiert und das heißt
Hongkongs Position und viel damit zu tun
das ist das finanztor in und aus dem
asiatischen riesen ist es verfügt also
über einen großen Vorteil den Singapur
nicht hat aber eben auch über einen
großen Nachteil da das pseudo
kommunistische Regime in Peking die
Freiheit in Hongkong immer weiter
abschnürt ja tatsache ist dass die
Schweiz in den letzten zwei
Jahrhunderten einen Zufluchtsort für die
großen Vermögen darstellte und zwar
genau zu der Zeit als der Westen die
einzige wirklich reiche blühende und
wohlhabende Region auf dem ganzen
Planeten war
und seit einiger Zeit hat sich Singapur
so etwas sehr sehr ähnlichem in Asien
entwickelt es hat ein offenes sicheres
und solides geschäftsspar und
investitionsumfeld hervorgebracht denn
wenn wir über den Reichtum der Asiaten
sprechen dürfte nicht vergessen dass
nicht nur China gemeint ist nein viele
andere Volkswirtschaften in der Region
sind stark im kommen superfügen
beispielsweise Indonesien Malaysia und
Vietnam für die kommenden Jahrzehnte
über durchaus erstaunliche Prognosen und
sie alle sind nur einen Katzensprung vom
kleinen Stadt Singapur entfernt und als
ob das noch nicht genug wäre sind auch
etablierte Schwergewichte wie Japan und
Südkorea so wie eben auch China relativ
nicht allzu weit entfernt die große
Preisfrage lautet also ob diese
ungewöhnliche südostasiatische
Stadtstaat tatsächlich die nächste
Schweiz werden könnte oder zumindest die
Schweiz Asiens woher stammt all der
Reichtum der nach Singapur fließt und
was genau sind die Gründe aus den viele
vermögende Menschen genau diesen Ort
wählen um dort ihr Geld zu parken aber
auch um dort zu leben zu arbeiten und
Unternehmen zu gründen diese und viele
andere interessante Fragen zu Singapur
werden wir im heutigen Video beantworten
also fangen wir ohne weitere Umschweife
an
[Musik]
die Hüter des Mammuts
Schweiz bleibt ein wichtiger
Zufluchtsort für globales Vermögen laut
die Leute verwaltete die helvetische
Finanzindustrie im Jahr 2020 ein
internationales Vermögen von 2,6
Billionen US-Dollar insgesamt übersteigt
ihr Finanzvermögen im Jahr 2021 4,1
Billionen Dollar das sind fast 40 % mehr
als das gesamte Finanzsystem eines
Landes wie Spanien ist in der
Bevölkerung in meine fünfeinhalb mal so
groß ist wie die der Schweiz nun
Singapur liegt ja immer noch weiter
zurück insgesamt verwaltet sein
Finanzsystem laut der Basler Bank für
internationalen Zahlungsausgleich nur
etwas mehr als 2 Billionen Dollar an
Vermögenswerten also etwa halb so viel
wie das Schweizer System aber es wächst
wesentlich schneller Singapur entwickelt
sich zu Sehens zu einem wichtigen
Zentrum für Vermögensverwaltung in Asien
und droht selbst Hongkong zu überholen
wir haben hier auch visualpolitik schon
mehrfach darüber gesprochen dass ich
impings Angriff auf Hongkong der
ehemaligen britischen grundkolonie einen
wenig schmeichelhaften Ruf eingebracht
hat
[Musik]
früher bildete sie das traditionelle
Epizentrum der Geschäftsfelder Region
quasi das Finanzielle Herz Asiens nun ja
ihr kennt die Geschichte mit der
Rechtssicherheit ist es nicht mehr so
gut bestellt nachdem die chinesischen
Behörden an den fahndungstisch kamen
internationale Vereinbarungen umgingen
und die Stadt übernahmen und es geht mit
ihr weiter bergab was wenig überraschend
extrem abschreckend wird auf
internationales Kapital und Investoren
ich meine wer will das eigene Geld an
einem Ort aufbewahren der unter der
Kontrolle von Pink steht würdet ihr
darauf vertrauen dass es nicht
irgendwann einfach futsch wäre wenn er
es darauf anlegt ganz genau also nein
Danke und das betrifft logischerweise
der internationalen Investoren aber auch
die großen chinesischen Portfolios die
Hongkong bisher als Fluchtweg genutzt
haben für sie war es bisher das
Schließfach außerhalb der Reichweite der
Kommunistischen Partei Chinas aber
dieses Schließfach ist eben nicht mehr
sicher vor dem Zugriff der KPC und wenn
Hongkong keine Lösung mehr darstellt
oder die Sicherheit des Geldes auch
zumindest nicht mehr vollständig
garantiert ist ist an der Zeit wo anders
Zuflucht zu suchen und wisst ihr was das
ist genau der Grund warum die
Finanzindustrie in Singapur momentan
einen Boom erlebt alles deutet daraufhin
ein paar Jahren nicht nur hongkon als
wichtigste ist wenn ein Zentrum Asien
ablösen wird sondern auch für
asiatischen Kontinent das sein wird was
die Schweiz für den Rest der Welt heute
ist
auch die Leute ist zwar das
international Marktvolumen in Hongkong
also die Anzahl der Transaktion mit
aktieneinlagen in diesem anderen Anlagen
zwischen 2010 und 2016 schneller
gewachsen als in Singapur von da an
begann sich die Lage jedoch zu ändern ab
2016 viel Hongkong bereits unter das
Wachstum Singapurs zwischen 2017 und 22
und ihr wisst was 2020 kam alle
Prognosen besagen daher das ist für
Hongkong nur noch schlimmer werden wird
der Finanzsektor in Hongkong wächst zwar
noch immer aber seine Dynamik ist nicht
mehr dieselbe Singapur hingegen wächst
stetig und immer schneller
[Musik]
okay jetzt haltet euch aber fest denn
Finanzinvestitionen sind nicht das
Einzige mit dem sich Singapur auf dem
Fortnite befindet ganz und gar nicht
gewaltiges Summen ausländischer Gelder
Fliesen auch in Form von
Direktinvestitionen z.B durch die
Gründung von Unternehmen oder den Kauf
von Immobilien und wir euch vorstellen
könntest einer der größten Akteure in
diesen Prozess natürlich das chinesische
Kapital die Pandemie und die verrückte
no corbit-politik haben diesen Prozess
nochmals beschleunigt aber wir sprechen
hier von einem grundlegenden Interessen
[Musik]
nach Angaben der Financial Times ist die
Zahl der Family Offices also der Fonds
oder investitionsplattformen die große
Vermögen einzelner Familien verwalten in
Singapur zwischen 2018 und 2021 um
1.400% gestiegen die Zahl der Fonds ist
von etwa 50 auf mehr als 700 gesprungen
und es wird geschätzt dass das Ende 2022
sogar schon 1500 gewesen sein könnten
davon wurden 40 % auf Kapital aus der
sogenannten Volksrepublik China
einfallen allein im Jahr 2022 wurden 500
chinesische Unternehmen in Singapur
registrieren von dort aus werden sie
Investitionen in Länder wie Indien und
viele andere Punkte Orte in der Region
lenken
und falls jemand dachte dass sich die
Dinge nach dem Ende der Null
kubik-politik in China beruhigen würden
dann deutet alles drauf hin dass es
jetzt erst richtig losgehen 27 Februar
2023 während sich China wieder öffnet
beginnt sich die Flucht reicher Chinesen
nach Singapur zu beschleunigen und siehe
da nach Angaben des
Beratungsunternehmens Henry and partners
das vermögende Privatpersonen bei der
Beschaffung von wohnsitzenden außen
unterwegs kam im Jahr 2020 und 2800 neue
reiche nach Singapur damit ist es nach
den Vereinigten Arabischen Emiraten und
Australien das tritt beliebteste Ziel
für Superreiche nebenbei bemerkt die
Schweiz liegt mit 229 wohl haben einen
Ausländer pro Jahr auf Platz 5 dieser
Rangliste und obwohl Singapur die
Nationalität der neuen Einwohner nicht
veröffentlicht wird geschätzt dass es
sich bei den meisten von ihnen um
Chinesen handelt mit anderen Worten
viele wohl haben sich Chinesen haben
während des Wahnsinns die Zeichen
derzeit erkannt und setzen nun dass sie
sich wieder frei bewegen können auf die
Flucht ins Ausland und ja der
hauptflucht und heißt Zweifel daran
besteht
Jumping
außerdem befürchten viele dieser
chinesische Superreichen das Pickings
Duldung großes Land und Unternehmen aus
dem Land gehen zu lassen bald zu Ende
sein könnte es könnte sogar zu
Einschränkungen solcher Bewegungen
kommen und viele glauben daher dass ihr
Vermögen nie wieder in Sicherheit
bringen können wenn sie es nicht jetzt
tun dies ist der repräsentativ für die
Gruppe Politik und das Bestreben der
Kommunistischen Partei Chinas das Leben
und die Freiheiten der Menschen
einzuschränken um sich auf das
Schlimmste vorzubereiten müssen Sie also
Ihr Sicherungsnetz ins Ausland ausweiten
ein weiterer wichtiger Grund warum die
Wahl viele große chinesischer Vermögen
ausgerechnet auf Singapur gefallen ist
hat mit der russischen Invasion in der
Ukraine zu tun ja tatsächlich mit der
Ukraine so weiter Konflikt von Singapur
auch entfernt sein mag aber was in aller
Welt hat die Ukraine mit Singapur zu tun
nun lasst mich das erklären das
Misstrauen gegenüber things zunehmender
nationalistischer Version führt starke
Zweifel und Ängste das am Ende
ernsthafte Maßnahmen gegen Taiwan
ergreifen könnte was wiederum den besten
dazu bringen könnte Sanktionen gegen
China zu verhängen deshalb entscheiden
sich viele Chinesen verorte die
neutraler sein könnten anstatt ihren
Reichtum nur nach Europa oder in die
Vereinigten Staaten zu bringen und
Singapur erfüllt eben all diese
Anforderungen und all das hat natürlich
auch Auswirkungen auf lokaler Ebene
so stiegen die Wohnungspreise eines
Singapur allein im Jahr 2022 um 8,6 %
und macht Analysen zufolge kauft nicht
chinesische Käufer von allen
ausländischen Käufern die meisten
Eigentumswohnungen vergiss bitte auch
nicht dass wir von einem Kleinstadt mit
nur 5,6 Millionen Einwohnern auf einer
Fläche knapp zu groß wie Hamburg
sprechen und fast die Hälfte die sowieso
schon winzigen Staatsgebiets besteht aus
Bergen und Naturschutzgebieten ihr könnt
euch also vorstellen dass es nicht so
einfach ist einfach immer mehr Wohnungen
zu bauen um die hohe Nachfrage zu
befriedigen das ist in der Tat eines der
größten Probleme der Stadt aber wir
werden heute nicht näher darauf eingehen
denn wir haben bereits einen frühen
Video über das Wohnungsprobleme Singapur
gesprochen und vor allem wie man es dort
gelöst hat aber abgesehen von dieser
Frage was genau bietet Singapur den
Chinesen das so viele von ihnen
plötzlich vor schieße wachsendem
Autoritarismus dort Zuflucht suchen
nun der Stadtstaat ist tatsächlich
besonders attraktiv für Chinesen er
liegt in der Nähe Hongkongs und des
chinesischen Festlands und drei Viertel
der Bevölkerung sind bereits Chinesen
das hat zur Folge dass neben Englisch
auch immer darin weit verbreitet ist so
dass die sprachlichen und kulturellen
Barrieren eher gering sind in Singapur
doch einige der besten Schulen und
Universitäten der Welt angesiedelt das
ist ein Faktor den chinesische Familien
besonders schätzen natürlich verfügt die
Stadt auch über einen gut entwickelte
vermögensverwaltungsbranche und zu allem
Überfluss ermöglicht die starke Präsenz
chinesische Unternehmen im Land das
Entstehen eines Komplex nicht
chinesischen wirtschaftsklasse
chinesische Unternehmen den die beliebte
tiktok-app gehört hat zum Beispiel eine
große Niederlassung in Singapur und
tatsächlich das ist darauf seine Präsenz
noch weiter auszubauen bis sie praktisch
isch zu einer Art zweitem
Eigentümer bei Dance will über drei
Jahre Milliarden in Singapur investieren
das Unternehmen plant Milliarden von
Dollar zu investieren und hunderte von
Mitarbeitern in Singapur einzustellen
nachdem es sich dafür entschieden hat
seinen regionalen Hauptsitz für
Südostasien dort anzusiedeln das ist nur
ein Beispiel unter Dutzenden die wir
hier aufzählen können
[Musik]
denn die Wahrheit ist dass sich Singapur
auch zu einem wichtigen Zentrum für
Technologieunternehmen entwickelt vor
allem für solche die im Finanzbereich
tätig sind und natürlich verfügt diese
Stadt über eine erstklassige
technologische Infrastruktur ein
erstklassiges Bildungssystem das sehr
auf Informationstechnologien
ausgerichtet ist eine nicht zu dichte
regulierungsumgebung und eine Menge
Finanzunternehmen mit anderen Worten
finden Text befinden sich hier in ihrem
Element in der Tat ist dies vielleicht
einer der florierendsten Sektoren ist
Singapur aber nicht der einzige wollt
ihr wissen warum die singapurische
Wirtschaft ihre größte Zukunft noch vor
sich hat auf welche Weise Singapur
nichts geringer als als reichste Land
der Welt werden will dann passt jetzt
gut auf
[Musik]
das Singapur der Zukunft
übrigens wusstet ihr das Singapur das
umweltfreundlichste Land Asiens ist in
studienführender umweltinstitute
darunter daniel-university und der
Vereinten Nationen rangiert Singapur auf
den environmental performance Index
weltweit 14 und in ganz Asien sogar
erster Stelle ja ganz genau obwohl
Singapur ein dicht bewohnter Stadtstaat
ist mit einer unglaublich hohen
organisierungsrate hat es mit Hilfe
moderner Stadtplanung umweltfreundlichen
geboten und eine innovativen Ressourcen
und Energiewirtschaft die damit
verbundenen riesigen Umwelt
Herausforderungen gemeistert Singapur
ist ein besonders herausragendes
Beispiel dafür wie Umweltschutz und
wirtschaftliche Erfolg Hand in Hand
gehen wir haben zum Beispiel schon mal
ein ganzes Video darüber gedreht wie
Singapur seine Wasserwirtschaft so
aufgestellt hat dass es trotz seiner
kleinen Fläche und riesigen Bevölkerung
bei diesen wichtigen Rohstoff autark
bleibt und auch noch die Umwelt schont
ich werde es Euch natürlich verlinken
damit ihr es euch nachher ansehen könnt
vergessen bitte auch nicht unseren Kanal
zu abonnieren falls ihr es noch nicht
getan habt und unbedingt mit Glöckchen
um keines unserer Videos über der Art
interessante Element zu verpassen in
Singapur hat man nämlich begriffen dass
ein gesundes Verhältnis zur Umwelt und
nachhaltiges Wirtschaften auch die
Grundlagen wirklich langanhaltenden und
überragenden Wohlstand sind dies gilt
natürlich überall denn wenn man seine
Umwelt nicht gut behandelt bekommt man
irgendwann sowieso die dicke Rechnung
dafür daher finde ich dass wir dringend
etwas tun sollten um die Umwelt unseres
Planeten zu schützen aber nicht nur
irgendwas da durchaus konkrete Dinge
daher haben wir uns entschlossen mit
einem neuen frischen YouTube-Kanal
zusammen zu arbeiten der sich genau
dieser Aufgabe verschrieben hat er heißt
Planet wild am Ende dieses Videos werde
ich euch mehr über den YouTube-Kanal
meiner Freunde bei Planet Wald erzählen
bleibt also unbedingt dran aber zurück
nach Singapur
[Musik]
diese sowieso schon florierende Stadt an
der letzter Zeit noch eine viel größeren
Aufschwung erlebt sein starkes Wachstum
als Finanzzentrum und Zufluchtsort für
vermögende Privatpersonen ermöglicht es
der Regierung neue wirtschaftliche Ziele
zu setzen Ende 2022 hat sie ihre
Strategie bis 2030 festgelegt und die
Frage ist was genau willst Singapur bis
dahin werden wir gehen davon aus dass
einige der am weitesten entwickelten
Sektoren des Landes derzeit fintex
Biotechnologie und medizinischer
Tourismus sind
um euch einen Eindruck zu verschaffen
von den 100 lokalen Unternehmen mit dem
schnellsten Wachstum zwischen 2008 und
2021 befinden sich zehn fintechs 8 im
Bereich Logistik und Transport und
sieben im Bereich Energie und Versorgung
tatsächlich waren im Juni 2022 allein in
Singapur 1002 fintechs registriert
obwohl wahrscheinlich werdet ihr nicht
aus dem Stegreif sagen können ob das nun
viel oder wenig ist
[Musik]
aber wenn wir sie mit den knapp 10.000
fintech vergleichen die es in den USA
gibt der wohlgemerkt dem Weltmarktführer
wird schnell klar das ist in Singapur
eine Menge davon gibt ja ganz genau in
den Vereinigten Staaten nehmen
Weltmarktführer in diesem Bereich haben
sich nur etwa 10 mal so viele fintech
Unternehmen angesiedelt wenn Singapur
obwohl die USA stolze 59 mal mehr
Einwohner haben aber wir reden hier
nicht nur über die digitale Welt was
wäre wenn ich euch sagen würde dass
einer der Sektoren in letzter Zeit in
diesem kleinste Land am stärksten wuchs
das verarbeitende Gewerbe ist und was
wäre wenn ich euch verraten würde dass
diese Sektor die oberste Priorität des
2030 Plans darstellt ja obwohl Singapur
ein sehr kleiner Ort ist macht das
verarbeitende Gewerbe 22% des BIP aus
zum Vergleich in Spanien Frankreich und
Großbritannien Betrieb der Anteil dieses
Sektors nur 13 10 bzw 09% tatsächlich
ist einer von acht Arbeitsplätze
Singapur im verarbeitenden Gewerbe
angesiedelt wie ihr seht besteht die
Stadt also nicht nur aus großen
Wolkenkratzer mit Banken und
Versicherung Singapur hat viel mehr zu
bieten seinem Volkswirtschaft ist
hochgradig divers allerdings falls ihr
bei verarbeitenden Gewerbe an Schuh oder
spielzeugfabriken denkt das könnt ihr
euch direkt wieder aus dem Kopf schlagen
[Musik]
nein Singapur ist auf hochmoderne
wertschöpfungsintensive Produktion
spezialisiert zum Beispiel in der
Elektronikbranche dazu gehören die
Halbleiterindustrie die Feinmechanik die
chemische Industrie und auch die
Produktion von Komponenten für die Luft
und Raumfahrtindustrie insgesamt
entfallen rund 80% der gesamten
Produktion auf fortschrittliche
Industrie
so wie es der Schweiz gelungen ist
hochspezialisierte und hoch entwickelte
Branchen wie die biomedizinindustrie zu
schaffen verfolgt Singapur hier einen
ganz ähnlichen Ansatz allerdings will
die Regierung jetzt noch viel weiter
gehen und hat einen Plan aufgestellt in
dem Robotik und künstliche Intelligenz
eine Schlüsselrolle spielen das Ziel ist
es lokale Arbeitsplätze mit geringer
wirtschaftung auf ein absolutes Minimum
zu reduzieren
die Idee dahinter ist nicht nur dass die
Zahl der Arbeitsplätze mit geringer
Wertschöpfung reduziert wird dann auch
dass diejenigen die sie ausüben sowieso
täglich aus dem malaysischen Grenzstadt
Johann pendeln und tatsächlich ist der
Stadt bereits auf den richtigen Weg
dieses Ziel zu erreichen um euch eine
Vorstellung zu geben im 5 Jahreszeitraum
2017 ist 21 stieg die Arbeitsprodukte in
verarbeitenden Gewerbe und
durchschnittlich 11,9% pro Jahr
aber warum glaube ich Singapurer nun
eigentlich dass sie das verarbeitende
Gewerbe noch weiter stärken müssen
anstatt sich zum Beispiel mit voller
Kraft auf den Dienstleistungssektor zu
spezialisieren nun dazu müsst ihr wissen
dass die Regierung ähnlich wie die
Schweizer sich nicht damit zufrieden
gibt alles auf bankenversicherungen oder
die Investmentindustrie zu setzen und
stattdessen versucht eine starke lokale
Industrie zu fördern eine Industrie die
nicht so stark dem Auf und Ab der
Weltwirtschaft ausgesetzt ist mit
anderen Worten es geht um Resilienz und
Diversifizierung aber in Bereichen mit
sehr hoher Wertschöpfung
tja und dann versucht Singapur
tatsächlich doch auch etwas Ähnliches
mit dem Primärsektor die Regierung
fördert die Gründung von hightech-farmen
im ganzen Land um immer weniger von
Nahrungsmittel Importen abhängig zu sein
und jetzt haltet euch fest alles in
allem ist ist eine Tatsache das Singapur
offenbar alle notwendigen
Voraussetzungen hat um all diese Ziele
zu erreichen eine große Anzahl
hochqualifizierter Fachkräfte eine
riesige Menge an Kapital das bereiteten
alle Arten von Projekten zu investieren
eine robuste Rechtssicherheit niedrige
Steuern eine erstklassige Infrastruktur
und Kommunikation und darüber hinaus
eine lange Schlange eine Fachkräften und
Investoren die nur darauf warten ins
Land zu ziehen ihr seht also Singapur
scheint wirklich kurz davor zu stehen
die neue Schweiz zu werden mit einer
sehr ähnlichen Erfolgsformel die
allerdings an die heutige Zeit und den
regionalen Kontext angepasst wurde
bisher sind die Schweizer immer noch
reicher aber das könnte sich sehr bald
ändern ja wie ihr seht gibt es viele
gute Gründe dafür dass wir den Vorbild
Singapur noch viele weitere Videos
widmen werden aber bis dahin seid
erstmal ihr in der Reihe was könnte sich
eurer Meinung nach euer Land voll
Singapur abschauen ist es der Fokus auf
die Hightech Industrie den Umweltschutz
oder das Modell vermögende
Privatpersonen anzuziehen oder geht es
wie so oft darum den richtigen Mix zu
finden welche Formel wäre für euer Land
ideal wie immer sind wir auf eure
Diskussion zu diesem Thema schon mächtig
gespannt jetzt habe ich für euch aber
noch eine einzigartige Empfehlung hier
auf Youtube Planet Wald ist eine globale
Community von Menschen die in die
Zukunft unseres Planeten am Herzen liegt
und die etwas für den Schutz unserer
Natur tun möchten die Mitglieder
finanzieren jeden Monat durch ihre
Beiträge ein neues Naturschutzprojekt
ich bin total davon und ihr könnt das
auch sein Planet weil es so inspirierend
weil sie Naturschutz mit aktiven Handeln
spannenden Hintergrundwissen und
Unterhaltung verbinden könnt ihr euch
noch anders massive Fisch Sterben von
2022 in der oder erinnern Blender du alt
war jetzt vor Ort und unterstützt die
Stärkung des Ökosystems oder in diesem
Video hier gehen sie gegen Waldbrände
auf Sizilien vor was ihr auch hier bei
uns ein immer stärkeres Problem für
Natur und Mensch wird also schaut euch
jetzt unbedingt die Plan et Videos an
ich hoffe dass euch das heutige Video
gefallen hat und ihr vielleicht etwas
dabei gelernt habt falls ja gibt uns
bitte ein Like und teilt es mit euren
Freunden in der Videobeschreibung findet
ihr auch einen Link mit dem ihr unsere
Arbeit durch eine freiwillige Spende
unterstützen könnt macht's gut und bis
bald
[Musik]